bonsoir mademoiselle comment allez-vous
vous allez bien vous c'est votre
troisième film d'emmanuelle bercot
il ya quelque chose de spécial quand
vous êtes avec elle c'est différent les
affectionne vraiment différent quand
elle vous dirige qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez l'expliquer nous avons quand même
c'est à dire qu'elle est ou de caractère
c'est quelqu'un de bien mais là
évidemment pour votre caractère même est
très bas si l'on préfère mais exigeant
et demande beaucoup veulent vous avez
vous couleurs et d'anciennes elle vous
demande quelque chose de très très
difficile dans ce final vous demande
quelque chose de difficile c'est un vrai
mélo en même temps ça va très très loin
c'est une des relations elles devront
déjà au départ un scénario qui est très
bon rythme très délicat 10 à venir à
cannes c'est un bonheur pour vous
non je te contentes que calais vous
ouvrir les coeurs
ma ouvrir avant là et qu'on ne voudrait
prendre sa commande comme avant c'est
vraiment une émouvante pour moi oui je
vous laisse monter les marches
merci infiniment catherine deneuve nine
avec nous